good morning John it is morning which it
usually is now when I make did I say
that out loud I'm going to take you
through a day in the life of me and just
it on my morning baby stuff and now I'm
coming up to the office I don't have
anything on my calendar until around
11:00
so until then arrives I'm working on a
song which I haven't done in a while I
was gonna try to do it as a song
Wednesday but it's just not happening
all right songwriting over I did put it
on my tumblr it still has some problems
but if you want to listen to it it's
there now it's time to choose which
pizza shirt I'm gonna put on Joe's this
drippy pizza I'm to go Mike's I forgot
my computer everyone at work will be
shocked shocked when I am late for the
first meeting of the day which I am at
the dftba warehouse we're having our
staff meeting as a pretty snowy mountain
out there that's nice dftba.com figures
out how to make cool stuff for online
creators and also how to get that stuff
to people who want it basically in this
meeting we had a bunch of cool ideas for
cool things to make and then we talked
about how the things that we are
currently making are doing everyone is
very excited about pizza this is Rachel
she designs the socks too you can tell
by her shirt this is just a freaking
great 2017 license plate right there
work candy corn flavored M&Ms oh that's
not good there that's so bad it tastes
like you like this was a mistake
Go Go staff meeting I beat you upstairs
that our main office we have the events
team mostly VidCon but also pod con this
staff meeting was gathering to talk
about the new space the Anaheim
Convention Center has some pod con
marketing ideas so we can sell more
tickets and the trip that two people
took to see how Blizzcon uses the
Convention Center in Anaheim so we can
steal ideas from Blizzcon he was about
now that I realized that I had no
scheduled time for lunch
luckily that meeting ended soon so I
went and got a burrito I mean
yes they just painted this on this
building and as they were doing it and
noticed different spacing on the sides
oh god it's gonna be there forever
pumpkins going down to the studio oh my
god it's cold down here I just forget I
need wardrobe my shirts I really enjoy
shooting scishow and crash course even
if it is pretty draining the scripts are
always really good these days our
writing staff is legitimately one of the
best in popular science writing in my
opinion we shot a bunch of scripts
including one about animals we thought
we were extinct but weren't for scishow
and one about why gratitude is so good
for people for scishow psyche which is
our new psychology Channel now I'm going
to how to adult to a dog how to adult is
one of our less well-known channels this
video what we were making today was on
how to create and send good thank-you
cards that one unsurprisingly will come
out around Thanksgiving alright I'm done
shooting it's 326 so I have a half an
hour before big staff meeting during
which I can maybe answer emails I don't
know well find out writing good emails
is a is a learned skill some people are
very good at it this is a good email
somebody sent me bad bad news enough for
me but it was done really well
good job person hockey he all the
flavors there's still a chair and then
we had our big all staff meeting which
we only do once a month here the VidCon
dftba and complexly staffs all get
together to keep each other up to date
on the big picture of what's happening
at each company I feel like these staff
meetings could be super boring but
actually they're very entertaining and I
find them to be one of my favorite times
of the day which is I feel like not
usually how staff meetings go and then I
go home I just finished my burrito I'm
gonna put a baby number and babies in
bed I had dinner back up to my office to
take a phone call and edit a video so
that's usually roughly how my days go
about some eating lots of shooting and
some creative process if thrown and
usually they don't end up with me
editing a video at 10 o'clock at night
but it's Pizza Mis and I'm not
complaining John I honestly can't wait
to see what you come up with tomorrow
it's so fun to have like some creative
pressure I mean it's hard but it's fun I
love pizza mess and I'll see what you
got for me tomorrow